Connor's too healthy for his own good. Connor is like this crazy runner. Pause. I need to go put coconut milk or coconut milk and kale in this curry thing. And I just want to wring his little neck. I'm bad at zero-indexing. Yeah, yeah, this is just a bit to put into the intro part. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode one, recorded on November 22nd, 2020. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we're going to be revisiting Stood, Transform, Reduce, and other unfinished topics from episode zero. The original question for episode zero, the original question for episode zero was,
Connor 的健康程度简直到了过犹不及的地步。Connor 就像个疯狂的跑步者。暂停。我得去把椰奶或者椰奶和羽衣甘蓝加到这个咖喱里。我真想掐住他那细脖子。我不擅长从零开始索引。对，对，这只是为了加到开场白里。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客，第一集，录制于 2020 年 11 月 22 日。我是 Connor，今天和我的联合主持人 Bryce 一起，我们将重温第零集中的 Stood、Transform、Reduce 以及其他未完成的话题。第零集的原始问题，第零集的原始问题是，
what is your favorite algorithm? Like, favorite algorithm singular. And we have feature creeped way past that. I think we covered like four algorithms in episode zero. So this is, I guess, part two. Yeah. So, yeah. So before we get into that, because we're going to talk more about Transform Reduce, because this podcast is called Algorithms Plus Data Structures Equals Programs, but it's really Transform Reduce. This podcast is called Algorithms plus Data Structures equals Programs, but it's really TransformReduce equals Programs. So we're going to talk about TransformReduce,
你最喜欢的算法是什么？就像，最喜欢的算法，单数。我们已经把功能范围扩展得远超于此了。我想我们在第零集里大概讲了四个算法。所以这大概是第二部分。对。所以，在进入正题之前，因为我们要更多地讨论 Transform Reduce，因为这个播客叫“算法加数据结构等于程序”，但实际上是 Transform Reduce。这个播客叫“算法加数据结构等于程序”，但实际上是 TransformReduce 等于程序。所以我们要讨论 TransformReduce，
I'm sure, a lot throughout this podcast, but today we're going to talk specifically about it a bit more. But before we do that, we should explain a little bit about our jobs and our background, because that's relevant to our passion for Transform Reduce. Have we started the podcast? Yeah, this is the podcast. This is the podcast right now. All right. I had no idea we started. So what are we talking about now? We're explaining all right, where we work. All right, you go ahead. Okay. So both of us now work at NVIDIA. That wasn't always the case. You didn't work at NVIDIA. And then I was like, Connor needs to work at NVIDIA.
我相信，在整个播客中会经常提到，但今天我们要专门多聊聊它。但在那之前，我们应该先介绍一下我们的工作和背景，因为这与我们对 Transform Reduce 的热情有关。我们开始录播客了吗？对，这就是播客。现在就是播客。好吧。我完全不知道我们已经开始了。那我们现在在聊什么？我们在解释，好吧，我们在哪里工作。好吧，你先请。好的。所以我们俩现在都在 NVIDIA 工作。以前并非如此。你以前不在 NVIDIA 工作。然后我就说，Connor 你得来 NVIDIA 工作。
But so I work at NVIDIA and my team works on what's called our C++ core compute libraries. And one of those libraries is a algorithms library called Thrust. So in particular, it's a parallel algorithms library. And for me, the reason why Transform Reduce is so exciting is because it is, I'd argue, the most powerful of the C++ parallel algorithms. And we'll talk a little bit more about that later. But you should explain...
但我现在在 NVIDIA 工作，我的团队负责所谓的 C++ 核心计算库。其中一个库是名为 Thrust 的算法库。具体来说，它是一个并行算法库。对我来说，Transform Reduce 之所以如此令人兴奋，是因为我认为它是 C++ 并行算法中最强大的一个。稍后我们会详细讨论。但你应该解释一下……
So I'm coming from this as the implementer of the algorithm, whereas you are actually one of my users. True. So also too, before I start talking, explain to folks, because I envision that over time, less and less of like, I assume at the start, a high concentration or percentage of our listeners will be C++ developers. But over time, that proportion will decrease as other listeners join. So I started my career as a C++ developer. I spent a year at Amazon doing a bit of C++, Java, Python, a tiny bit of Go, a tiny bit of Perl. And now I'm back to doing C++ and a little bit of Python.
所以我作为算法的实现者来谈论这个，而你实际上是我的用户。没错。还有，在我开始说之前，先向大家解释一下，因为我设想随着时间的推移，虽然我假设刚开始时，我们听众中 C++ 开发者的比例会很高。但随着其他听众的加入，这个比例会下降。所以我职业生涯的起点是 C++ 开发者。我在亚马逊工作了一年，做了一些 C++、Java、Python，一点点 Go，一点点 Perl。现在我又回到了 C++ 和一点点 Python 的工作中。
So what's your background? Have you been C++ from start to finish? So in episode zero, we talked about how I flunked out of college and started teaching myself to program in C++ to create a game. And then I discovered Boost through the Boost. The first algorithm I was exposed to was Boost's algorithm split. And then I quickly got distracted from the project I was working on by just contributing to Boost. And then I needed a job because I had, you know, dropped out of college. My parents were not super thrilled about me just like sitting in their basement. So I knew this guy on IRC, Hartmut Kaiser, and I was like, hey, I'm looking for a job. And he's like, hey,
那么你的背景是什么？你从始至终都是做 C++ 的吗？在第零集中，我们谈到了我是如何从大学退学，并开始自学 C++ 来开发游戏的。然后我通过 Boost 发现了 Boost。我接触的第一个算法是 Boost 的算法 split。然后我很快就因为参与 Boost 的贡献而偏离了原本的项目。然后我需要一份工作，因为你知道，我从大学退学了。我父母对我只是坐在地下室里并不太高兴。所以我认识 IRC 上的一个家伙，Hartmut Kaiser，我就说，嘿，我在找工作。他说，嘿，
why don't you come down to Louisiana? then I somehow talked my my parents into buying me a one-way me a 19 year old fairly sheltered child a one-way ticket to Louisiana and that worked out pretty well so I was there for a number of years working at Louisiana State University doing high performance computing, building parallel runtimes for scientific applications that run on supercomputers. And I did that for a few years. I worked on this thing called HPX.
你为什么不来路易斯安那州呢？然后我不知怎么说服了我父母给我买了一张单程票，我当时 19 岁，是个相当受保护的孩子，一张去路易斯安那州的单程票，结果还挺顺利的。所以我在那里待了几年，在路易斯安那州立大学工作，从事高性能计算，为运行在超级计算机上的科学应用构建并行运行时。我做了几年。我参与了一个叫 HPX 的项目。
And then I went to Lawrence Berkeley National Lab in Berkeley, California, and I did some other HPC stuff. And then I came to work at NVIDIA. And throughout that entire time, I have almost exclusively programmed in C++. My old mentor, Hartmut, he used to say, like, there's like three acceptable programming languages, C++, JavaScript, and Python. And so that's basically all that I've ever really worked with. Maybe with the exception of I interact a bit with Fortran. I have a weird passion for COBOL, in particular the history of COBOL.
然后我去了加州伯克利的劳伦斯伯克利国家实验室，做了一些其他的 HPC 工作。然后我来到 NVIDIA 工作。在那整个期间，我几乎只用 C++ 编程。我的老导师 Hartmut 过去常说，有三种可接受的编程语言：C++、JavaScript 和 Python。所以这基本上就是我真正用过的所有语言。也许除了我偶尔接触一点 Fortran。我对 COBOL 有一种奇怪的热情，特别是 COBOL 的历史。
And I write a lot of bash scripts and uh I think bash is actually like a pretty great programming language so we'll save we'll save bash for a whole episode we'll save the history of COBOL for another episode uh but do you know why uh Hartmut said that those three javascript python and c++ are the only three that you what did he say they're only three that are uh real c++ are the only three that you what did he say they're only three that are real programming languages or the only three you need to know like in his mind like those are the three the three acceptable programming language like like if you knew those three programming languages like c++ wasn't the answer for all problems he
我写了很多 bash 脚本，而且我认为 bash 其实是一种非常棒的编程语言，所以我们把 bash 留到整整一集去讲，把 COBOL 的历史留到另一集去讲。但你知道为什么 Hartmut 说那三种——JavaScript、Python 和 C++ 是仅有的三种你……他怎么说的？它们是仅有的三种……真正的……C++ 是仅有的三种你……他怎么说的？它们是仅有的三种真正的编程语言，或者说仅有的三种你需要知道的语言？在他看来，那三种是仅有的三种可接受的编程语言。就像如果你知道那三种编程语言……C++ 并不是所有问题的答案，他
he admitted that he was first and foremost a c++ person but it wasn't always the answer for all problems. He admitted that. He was first and foremost a C++ person. But it wasn't always the answer for everything. And so if it wasn't the answer for something, then you should do that thing in either Python or JavaScript. And I don't particularly know the rationale. I mean, Python, it's a nice language. It's very popular in data science and in HPC, so maybe that's why. I don't know about JavaScript. I mean, I guess if you need to deal with some web technology, it's one of them. Okay. So to summarize, you're basically start to finish C++ with a little bit of Bash, Fortran, COBOL in the midst, and I'm the more of
他承认他首先是一个 C++ 人，但它并不总是所有问题的答案。他承认了这一点。他首先是一个 C++ 人。但它并不总是万能的。所以如果它不是某件事的答案，那么你应该用 Python 或 JavaScript 来做那件事。我不太清楚其中的逻辑。我是说，Python 是一门不错的语言。它在数据科学和 HPC 中非常流行，所以也许这就是原因。我不了解 JavaScript。我是说，我想如果你需要处理一些 Web 技术，它是其中之一。好吧。总结一下，你基本上从始至终都是 C++，中间夹杂着一点 Bash、Fortran、COBOL，而我更像是
the polyglot one, or polyglot developer, I should say. I take it back. There is one common theme between all those languages, and I suspect it's part of the reason why my mentor, Hartmut, liked them all. All of those languages are Python, C++ and JavaScript. They're all fundamentally multi-paradigm languages. They're not purely functional languages or purely imperative languages or purely object oriented languages. Instead, they support multiple different paradigms, which gives you, the programmer, a great deal of freedom in how you write and structure code.
多语言开发者，或者说多语言程序员。我收回前言。所有这些语言之间有一个共同点，我怀疑这就是我的导师 Hartmut 喜欢它们的原因。所有这些语言——Python、C++ 和 JavaScript。它们从根本上都是多范式语言。它们不是纯函数式语言，也不是纯命令式语言或纯面向对象语言。相反，它们支持多种不同的范式，这给了你，作为程序员，在编写和构建代码时极大的自由。
And that was something that I think was always valuable to Hartmut. you know, if he goes and looks at a problem, he'll come up with a solution for it, which combines the power of functional programming, object oriented programming, and, you know, the efficiency of just writing low level imperative code. So I think that's what he probably liked about all those languages. Yeah, that's a good point. Multi paradigm. I prefer multi paradigm languages, because then I get to write code the way that I want. So before our tangent into the three acceptable programming languages, according to Hartmut Kaiser, we were pointing out the fact that I am an implementer of a C++ algorithms library, and you are now a consumer. So why don't you explain a little bit about where you come from?
我认为这对 Hartmut 来说一直很有价值。你知道，如果他去研究一个问题，他会想出一个解决方案，结合了函数式编程、面向对象编程的力量，以及编写底层命令式代码的效率。所以我认为这可能就是他喜欢所有这些语言的原因。是的，说得好。多范式。我更喜欢多范式语言，因为这样我就可以按照我想要的方式编写代码。所以在我们偏离到 Hartmut Kaiser 所说的三种可接受的编程语言之前，我们指出我是一个 C++ 算法库的实现者，而你现在是一个使用者。所以你为什么不解释一下你的背景？
So, yeah, in a nutshell, I work for a team called Rapids. That's all capital letters. At NVIDIA. Yeah, at NVIDIA. And this is sort of a newer kind of team for NVIDIA in that we're entirely open source. So Thrust is obviously an open source library. But I think that's probably the first open source or like the major, at least the first major. It was the first open source library at NVIDIA. It is funny that both, you know, NVIDIA is a company not historically known
好的，简而言之，我在 NVIDIA 的一个叫 Rapids 的团队工作。那是全大写字母。是的，在 NVIDIA。这是一个对 NVIDIA 来说比较新的团队，因为我们完全是开源的。Thrust 显然是一个开源库。但我认为这可能是 NVIDIA 的第一个开源库，或者至少是主要的，第一个主要的。它是 NVIDIA 的第一个开源库。很有趣的是，虽然 NVIDIA 在历史上并不以开源闻名，
for open source, but both you and I work at NVIDIA and we both pretty much spend 100% of our time working on open source code or on open standards. Yeah. So the Rapids team, like from the bottom up, was built to be like a remote open source team. So all of our development happens on and through GitHub. I rarely have to like log into VPN because my day job is like working on PRs and issues that are posted on the Rapids project. So specifically, I work on CUDIF. The CU, the CU standsU stands for CUDA, and DF stands for DataFrame. But Rapids is a number of projects, not just CUDIF. But basically what Rapids is designed to be is an end-to-end data science pipeline that
但你和我都在 NVIDIA 工作，而且我们几乎 100% 的时间都花在开源代码或开放标准上。是的。所以 Rapids 团队从底层开始就是作为一个远程开源团队构建的。我们所有的开发都发生在 GitHub 上，并通过 GitHub 进行。我很少需要登录 VPN，因为我的日常工作就是处理 Rapids 项目上提交的 PR 和 issue。具体来说，我从事 CUDIF 的工作。CU 代表 CUDA，DF 代表 DataFrame。但 Rapids 是多个项目的集合，不仅仅是 CUDIF。但基本上，Rapids 被设计为一个端到端的数据科学流水线，
runs on the GPU. And each of the projects or repos within Rapids sort of targets an existing library that exists in sort of the data science ecosystem, but that doesn't run on the GPU. So specifically, KU-DF targets or tries to sort of maintain parity with a Python library called Pandas, which is extremely popular. So if you're a Python dev, I'm sure you've heard of Pandas. I believe we have QML. The ML in that repo stands for machine learning. That targets scikit-learn, if I believe. And then there's a ton of other repos and projects, QSpatial, QGraph. I won't go through them all, but it's a super, super exciting team.
运行在 GPU 上。Rapids 中的每个项目或仓库都针对数据科学生态系统中现有的某个库，但这些库通常不在 GPU 上运行。具体来说，KU-DF 旨在或试图与一个非常流行的 Python 库 Pandas 保持一致。所以如果你是 Python 开发者，我相信你一定听说过 Pandas。我相信我们还有 QML。该仓库中的 ML 代表机器学习。如果我没记错的话，它针对的是 scikit-learn。然后还有很多其他的仓库和项目，QSpatial、QGraph。我就不一一列举了，但这是一个非常、非常令人兴奋的团队。
I absolutely love the work that we're doing there. I write in C++14. We should be upgrading to C++17 in the next, I don't know, year or so. I think it depends. And it plays well into your background too, because you actually originally were schooled in actuarial science, which is a good fit for data science. Yeah, I went to school to study actuarial math, and there is a lot of sort of finance applications, I guess, that leverage data science. I would say, though, a lot of the work that I do is sort of abstract, with no specific domain in mind, which I actually love because I really care more about code quality and the code that I'm writing than I do actually on the product
我非常热爱我们在那里所做的工作。我用 C++14 编写代码。我们应该会在未来一年左右升级到 C++17。我想这取决于具体情况。这也与你的背景很契合，因为你最初是学精算学的，这非常适合数据科学。是的，我上学时学习精算数学，我想有很多金融应用利用了数据科学。不过，我想说的是，我所做的大部分工作都是抽象的，没有特定的领域，我其实很喜欢这一点，因为我更关心代码质量和我正在编写的代码，而不是最终构建的产品。
that's being built at the end of the day. I think it's awesome that there's a lot of like national labs and a lot of like really, really big corporations that need to crunch a ton of data that are leveraging this library. But at the end of the day, like I am at heart, like a library writer. I'm not like a app developer. Yeah. We're both fundamentally framework people. You know, one of the analogies I like to use is that, you know, software is sort of like a library. There's people that write, that author the books, the library authors, and then there's people who come in and read the books and use knowledge from the books to build actual concrete things. That's people who build, you know, end applications. And then, of course, there's, you know, the people who define the languages that you use
我认为有很多国家实验室和很多非常大的公司需要处理海量数据，并且正在利用这个库，这很棒。但归根结底，我本质上是一个库编写者。我不是那种应用开发者。是的。我们本质上都是框架开发者。你知道，我喜欢用的一个类比是，软件就像一个图书馆。有人编写书籍，即库作者，然后有人进来阅读书籍并利用书中的知识来构建具体的实物。这就是构建最终应用的人。当然，还有定义你用来编写书籍的语言的人，
to write the books, which we also do a part of because a large part of, you know, what we do is, or a large part of what I do, less so you, is work on programming language standards. Specifically, I spend a lot of my time on the C++ standard. But, you know, the data science world is actually sort of a good intro into why we both think transform-reduce is so awesome. So before we do that though i just realized i went on a ramble of you know rapids and why i think rapids is awesome and failed to mention how that makes me a consumer of thrust um which is the connection so uh rapids
这也是我们工作的一部分，因为我们所做的大部分工作，或者我所做的大部分工作（你做的较少），是致力于编程语言标准。具体来说，我花了很多时间在 C++ 标准上。但是，数据科学世界实际上是一个很好的切入点，可以解释为什么我们都认为 transform-reduce 是如此棒。但在那之前，我刚意识到我刚才关于 Rapids 以及为什么我认为 Rapids 很棒的话题扯远了，却忘了提到这如何使我成为 Thrust 的使用者，这就是联系所在。所以，Rapids
is heavily built on top of thrust um which is fantastic because when i came to NVIDIA and even still now I do not consider myself like a a GPU computing expert I'm not like anywhere near like the top of the distribution when it comes to writing like CUDA kernels but most of the time we're not writing CUDA kernels in Rapids we're just leveraging the work that's already been done in Thrust and so if you're familiar with the STL algorithms you basically just instead of writing std colon colon, you just write Thrust colon colon, and you're programming on the GPU. Fantastic. So yes, that's how I'm a consumer of, or Rapids is a consumer of Thrust. But yes, back to TransformReduce. Well, and like, let's say, here's a data science problem. Let's say that you've got census data, let's say,
在很大程度上是建立在 Thrust 之上的，这太棒了，因为当我来到 NVIDIA 时，甚至直到现在，我都不认为自己是 GPU 计算专家。在编写 CUDA 内核方面，我远没有达到顶尖水平，但大多数时候我们在 Rapids 中并不编写 CUDA 内核，我们只是利用 Thrust 中已经完成的工作。所以如果你熟悉 STL 算法，你基本上只需要把 std:: 换成 Thrust::，你就是在 GPU 上编程了。太棒了。所以是的，这就是我作为 Thrust 使用者的方式，或者说 Rapids 是 Thrust 的使用者。但回到 TransformReduce。好吧，假设有一个数据科学问题。假设你有普查数据，
US census data as one big data set. And you want to count some property of that data set. For example, you want to determine how many people are over 30, 30 years old in this huge data set? Well, one way you can do this is with transform reduce. So in that case, your transformation function is a function that takes, you know, a record for a person in this data set and returns true if that person is older than 30 and false otherwise. And then your reduction operation just, you know, adds up all the trues
比如美国普查数据作为一个大数据集。你想计算该数据集的某个属性。例如，你想确定在这个庞大的数据集中有多少人超过 30 岁？好吧，你可以用 transform reduce 来实现。在这种情况下，你的转换函数是一个函数，它接收数据集中的一条记录，如果该人超过 30 岁则返回 true，否则返回 false。然后你的归约操作只是把所有的 true
into some integer value. And you probably are using some big int type if your data set is really truly large. And this is a good approach to implementing this because transform reduce is inherently something that we can easily paralyze. The transformation is embarrassingly parallel. And then the reduction part, well, we know how to paralyze reductions. That's a fairly well-known science. And it can be done fairly efficiently. And so that's one really good example of how you can use transform reduce anytime that you need to count a property.
加到一个整数值中。如果你的数据集确实非常大，你可能需要使用某种大整数类型。这是一种实现此目的的好方法，因为 transform reduce 本质上是我们很容易并行化的东西。转换过程是极其容易并行的。然后归约部分，好吧，我们知道如何并行化归约。这是一门相当成熟的科学。而且可以相当高效地完成。所以这是一个很好的例子，说明当你需要计算某个属性时，如何使用 transform reduce。
So here's a question. While I'm listening to you explain that, you've got some record, you're either turning that record, you either turning that record into basically a one or a zero based on some property, and then you're just adding up those ones and zeros to get a total count. In my head, and I'm sure in some of the listeners' heads, they're thinking, why not just use a std reduce or a std accumulate, where your accumulator is the total count, and each element that's being passed into your reduction binary operation is doing the transform and the reduction at the same time. So it's taking the record and using some ternary expression or if statement, if greater than 30 or whatever your age is, add one, otherwise add zero. And this is something that I misunderstood, that there's a reason that that actually doesn't work when you are parallelizing your algorithm. You can't just take a std accumulate that's doing that reduction and change it to a std reduce.
所以有个问题。当我在听你解释时，你有一条记录，你根据某个属性将该记录转换为 1 或 0，然后你只是把这些 1 和 0 加起来得到总数。在我的脑海里，我相信在一些听众的脑海里，他们会想，为什么不直接使用 std reduce 或 std accumulate，其中你的累加器是总数，并且传递给归约二元操作的每个元素都在同时进行转换和归约？所以它接收记录并使用某种三元表达式或 if 语句，如果大于 30 或无论你的年龄是多少，加 1，否则加 0。这是我曾经误解的一点，即当你并行化算法时，这种方法实际上是行不通的。你不能仅仅拿一个正在进行那种归约的 std accumulate，然后把它改成 std reduce。
Do you want to explain why that is? Well, yeah, because in that case, that sort of reduction that you're describing, that reduction depends upon things happening in a certain order, right? It depends upon a left fold, right? Correct. Yeah. And a parallel reduce cannot be constrained in that way. If you always have to fold from the left, then you can't actually really parallelize things, right? Because then, you know, the second reduction that you're doing in the set is always going to depend on the first one, and the third one will always depend on the second one, etc., etc. And so the algorithm
你想解释一下为什么吗？好吧，是的，因为在这种情况下，你所描述的那种归约，那种归约依赖于事情按特定顺序发生，对吧？它依赖于左折叠，对吧？没错。是的。而并行 reduce 不能以那种方式受到限制。如果你总是必须从左边折叠，那么你就无法真正并行化，对吧？因为那样的话，集合中你做的第二次归约总是会依赖于第一次，而第三次总是会依赖于第二次，等等。所以该算法
becomes inherently sequential. And so you need to, like, a parallel reduce cannot make that guarantee, and thus something that might be a very natural way of writing the code sequ uh you have to adhere to like the two properties of the reduction operation for both std reduce and std transform reduce which is that they both need to be associative and commutative and in the binary operation that was doing the reduction using a std reduce when your first element element is the total count which is some sort of integer or big integer type and the second element is like your record type like there's no way that's going to work so you can say yes you'd need a fold left for that another way to say is like you don't have an associative and commutative operation so you need the transform from the transform reduce to like modify the data that you have such that the reduction that you do doesn't depend on order or isn't commutative or associative or is commutative and associative.
变得本质上是顺序的。所以你需要，像，并行 reduce 不能做出那种保证，因此，对于 std reduce 和 std transform reduce，你必须遵守归约操作的两个属性，即它们都需要是结合律和交换律的。而在使用 std reduce 进行归约的二元操作中，当你的第一个元素是总数（某种整数或大整数类型），而第二个元素是你的记录类型时，这根本行不通。所以你可以说，是的，你需要一个左折叠。另一种说法是，你没有结合律和交换律的操作，所以你需要 transform reduce 中的转换来修改你拥有的数据，使得你所做的归约不依赖于顺序，或者不是交换律和结合律的，或者它是交换律和结合律的。
So in this case, we're turning our record into just an integer or a big integer, which then when we have sort of like the running sum and a one or a zero, it doesn't matter what order you add those up, you're always going to end up with the correct answer at the end of the day, which is like, it's a super important insight, which I didn't have for, I don't know, a number of weeks. And if you don't know what, you know, associativity or commutativity means, here's a simple mental test that you can use to think about whether a reduction in your code is going to be paralyzable or not. If that reduction has heterogeneous types, so the left-hand side is a different type than the right-hand side. That probably means that
所以在这个例子中，我们将记录转换为整数或大整数，然后当我们有运行总和以及 1 或 0 时，无论你以什么顺序将它们加起来，最终你总会得到正确答案，这就像是一个非常重要的见解，我好几周都没意识到。如果你不知道结合律或交换律意味着什么，这里有一个简单的心理测试，你可以用来思考代码中的归约是否可以并行化。如果该归约具有异构类型，即左侧类型与右侧类型不同。这可能意味着
you are doing some stateful reduction into one of those two types. You know, the left-hand side has some accumulation of the running state of the algorithm. And that means that it's not an algorithm that you can, or that's not a pattern that you can paralyze. Yeah, that is a good way to think about it. Yeah. So another thing we should talk about is the R-ity of transform reduce. So actually, the first proposal I ever wrote on the C++ committee a sequential version of transform reduce inner product um uh takes two
你正在对其中一种类型进行某种有状态的归约。你知道，左侧有算法运行状态的某种累积。这意味着它不是你可以并行化的模式。是的，这是一种很好的思考方式。是的。所以我们应该谈论的另一件事是 transform reduce 的元数。实际上，我向 C++ 委员会提交的第一个提案是 transform reduce 的顺序版本，内积……它接收两个
input sequences and the transformation function that it applies takes one element from each of those two input sequences um and uh the parallel version we didn't have that the parallel version, we didn't have that. The parallel version, we were just going to ship transform reduce, just one form of it that took only a single input sequence. And I wrote this paper saying, hey, no, it's actually really useful to have the binary one. You can do very cool things with it, like a word count algorithm or something like doing a dot product with this binary transform reduce that takes two input sequences. users of the thrust library that I work on do is something that I think you've come to call a zip reduce where what if you have three input sequences or four input sequences etc yeah zip reduce is one of the names that I mentioned in a couple of my talks I think the transform reduce at the end of the day is the correct name, because as you point out, there is both a version that takes a single sequence or a single range and one that takes two sequences or two ranges. And in the single range version, you're not doing any zipping operation.
输入序列，它应用的转换函数接收来自这两个输入序列中每个序列的一个元素……而并行版本，我们没有那个。并行版本，我们没有那个。并行版本，我们只是打算发布 transform reduce，只发布一种只接收单个输入序列的形式。我写了这篇论文说，嘿，不，拥有二元版本实际上非常有用。你可以用它做非常酷的事情，比如单词计数算法，或者像用这个接收两个输入序列的二元 transform reduce 做点积。我工作的 Thrust 库的用户所做的是我称之为 zip reduce 的东西，如果你有三个输入序列或四个输入序列等，是的，zip reduce 是我在我的几次演讲中提到的名字之一，我认为 transform reduce 归根结底是正确的名字，因为正如你指出的，既有接收单个序列或单个范围的版本，也有接收两个序列或两个范围的版本。在单范围版本中，你没有进行任何 zip 操作。
But internally, I think of the two range version as an algorithm called zip reduce and in fact that is exactly what it's called um in certain functional programming languages like haskell the two range zipping and sort of transforming algorithm is called zip with um which i think is uh it's great that they highlight zip i'm not sure about the width, but definitely I like the zip. Yeah. And we don't, or we did not in the original C++ algorithms have an algorithm like zip,
但在内部，我认为双范围版本是一种叫 zip reduce 的算法，事实上，在某些函数式编程语言（如 Haskell）中，双范围 zip 和转换算法确实被称为 zip with，我认为这很好，他们强调了 zip，我不确定 with，但我肯定喜欢 zip。是的。而且我们没有，或者我们在最初的 C++ 算法中没有像 zip 这样的算法，
although now we have that with ranges, right? It is proposed in the, you know, a plan for C++ 23 ranges paper. So depending on how well you do getting stuff through LOOG, it might end up in C++23. We should explain. I am the chair of the C++ Committee's library design group. So my ability to manage a standardization process can have a very real impact on whether or not we're able to get cool stuff into the next revision of the C++ standard. But no pressure or anything. Yeah, no pressure. So a question, it sounds like, actually, I always thought, this came up, and I was on
虽然现在有了 ranges，对吧？它是在 C++ 23 ranges 论文的计划中提出的。所以取决于你在 LOOG 中推进事情的进展，它可能会进入 C++ 23。我们应该解释一下。我是 C++ 委员会库设计组的主席。所以我管理标准化过程的能力，对于我们是否能够将酷东西加入到 C++ 标准的下一个版本中，有着非常实际的影响。但别有压力。是的，没压力。所以有个问题，听起来，实际上，我一直认为，这出现了，而且我上周在
CppCast last week, and this came up that I had mentioned that TransformReduce was sort of the revamped parallel version of the STL algorithm inner product. And I pointed out the two differences, one being that, you know, there's tighter restrictions on transform reduce, and that transform reduce also takes a single range, whereas inner product, you can only take two ranges. And so I had always thought that transform reduce was actually just like an evolved version of inner product, where they added the extra single range. But it sounds like if you're writing a proposal to add the two ranges, that transform reduce started out as just like an entirely,
CppCast 上，提到了 TransformReduce 是 STL 算法 inner product 的改进并行版本。我指出了两个区别，一个是，你知道，transform reduce 有更严格的限制，另一个是 transform reduce 也可以接收单个范围，而 inner product 只能接收两个范围。所以我一直认为 transform reduce 实际上只是 inner product 的进化版本，他们添加了额外的单个范围。但听起来如果你正在写一个提案来添加两个范围，那么 transform reduce 最初只是一个完全的，
like it was designed as an algorithm on itself, not as an evolution of stood inner product. Do you know if that's the case? Yeah. So the C++ parallel algorithms are based on the Thrust library that I now work on. But at the time that they were being standardized, I worked on this parallel runtime called HPX and didn't work at NVIDIA and wasn't particularly familiar with the Thrust library. And the Thrust library had introduced transform reduce and i think the mentally the model there was it's an extended version of reduce it's a more efficient thing
它被设计为一个独立的算法，而不是 stood inner product 的进化。你知道是这样吗？是的。C++ 并行算法是基于我现在工作的 Thrust 库的。但在它们被标准化的时候，我在从事一个叫 HPX 的并行运行时工作，并没有在 NVIDIA 工作，也不是特别熟悉 Thrust 库。Thrust 库引入了 transform reduce，我想当时的思维模型是它是 reduce 的扩展版本，它比做一次 transform
to do than to do a transform or to do yet a transform uh followed by a reduction um and uh i think that's why it takes only a single input sequence because reduce only took a single input sequence. Whereas in HPX, we always thought of it as naturally being the parallel version of inner product. Although I should mention, thrust does have a parallel version of inner product under the name inner product. And that may have been a part of it, too, that the original plan was for transform reduced to just take a single input and for inner product to take two inputs, but for there to both be a sequential and a parallel version.
或者做一次 transform 后跟一次 reduction 更高效……而且我认为这就是它只接收单个输入序列的原因，因为 reduce 只接收单个输入序列。而在 HPX 中，我们总是认为它自然是 inner product 的并行版本。虽然我应该提到，Thrust 确实有一个叫 inner product 的并行版本。这可能也是其中的一部分，最初的计划是 transform reduce 只接收单个输入，而 inner product 接收两个输入，但两者都有顺序和并行版本。
And this is actually one of the big design questions about the parallel algorithms. Should we have parallel versions of the algorithms with the same name, even if the parallel version cannot provide the same guarantees as the sequential version. And in some cases, in most cases, we said, no, if the parallel version requires fundamentally different guarantees, then we should give it a new name and that's why in c++ we have both accumulate um a sequential algorithm that does reductions um but in a certain order um uh and reduce a uh which has a both a sequential and a version, but makes no guarantees about the ordering and requires commutivity and associativity. Interesting.
这实际上是并行算法的一个重大设计问题。我们是否应该为算法提供相同名称的并行版本，即使并行版本无法提供与顺序版本相同的保证？在某些情况下，在大多数情况下，我们说不，如果并行版本需要根本不同的保证，那么我们应该给它一个新名字，这就是为什么在 C++ 中我们既有 accumulate（一个执行归约的顺序算法，但按特定顺序），又有 reduce（既有顺序版本也有并行版本，但不保证顺序，并要求交换律和结合律）。有趣。
So I actually did not know Thrust had, I'm staring at the docs right now. We'll put it in the show notes, but Interproduct. So Interproduct is a parallel version of the STL Interproduct without the requirements on the binary operations. Is that, that's correct? Yeah, that's right. Yeah. Interesting. Yeah. So I would argue that that is something of a historical mistake in Thrust that we probably didn't really mean to do that um uh but it's you know it's a little bit too late to fix it now do what specifically have both inner product and transform reduce or
所以我其实不知道 Thrust 有，我正盯着文档看。我们会把它放在节目说明里，但 Interproduct。所以 Interproduct 是 STL Interproduct 的并行版本，没有对二元操作的要求。是这样吗？是的，没错。是的。有趣。是的。所以我认为这是 Thrust 的一个历史性错误，我们可能并不是真的想那样做……但你知道，现在修复它有点太晚了。你是说具体同时拥有 inner product 和 transform reduce，还是
oh no to have the to have a a a parallel inner product under that name was probably a mistake um because we don't have in thrust an algorithm called accumulate that's parallel. We don't have in thrust an algorithm called iota that's parallel. Out of recognition that those algorithms were like the name, those named algorithms in the standard library were inherently sequential. And so when we introduced those into our parallel algorithms library, we gave them different names so that people would not associate the semantics of the sequential one with the semantics of the parallel one. There's other algorithms like transform where there is no difference in guarantees aside from guarantees around race conditions between the sequential and the parallel version.
哦不，以那个名字拥有一个并行 inner product 可能是一个错误……因为我们在 Thrust 中没有一个叫 accumulate 的并行算法。我们在 Thrust 中没有一个叫 iota 的并行算法。这是出于一种认识，即标准库中那些命名的算法本质上是顺序的。所以当我们把它们引入我们的并行算法库时，我们给了它们不同的名字，这样人们就不会把顺序版本的语义与并行版本的语义联系起来。还有其他算法，比如 transform，除了关于顺序版本和并行版本之间竞争条件的保证外，没有其他保证上的区别。
And those guarantees around race conditions being essentially, you know, okay, if your transformation function, your transformation functions need to be thread safe. But there's no big difference like, hey, you know, the accumulate supports non-commutative, non-associative operations, whereas, you know, reduce doesn't. And so, you know, there's a lot of power in names because names associate semantics with them. And I think it was probably a mistake for us to use the name inner product, which has an association with those guarantees that std inner product makes.
而那些关于竞争条件的保证本质上是，你知道，好的，如果你的转换函数，你的转换函数需要是线程安全的。但没有像“嘿，你知道，accumulate 支持非交换、非结合操作，而 reduce 不支持”这样的大区别。所以，名字里有很多力量，因为名字将语义与它们联系起来。我认为我们使用 inner product 这个名字可能是一个错误，它与 std inner product 所做的那些保证有关联。
To use that name for a parallel algorithm that doesn't make those guarantees is probably a mistake interesting yeah well i feel like we've gone over time once again and i feel like there was there was a third topic we were supposed to because we were we were supposed to revisit all the stuff we said we would talk about in episode one and then we just sort of talk about triangle products. Oh, yeah, yeah. I can very quickly wrap up this episode by just saying that if you recall from episode zero what outer product was, to recap, basically a Cartesian product where you take two lists and you generate all possible combinations of the elements of those two lists, except a Cartesian product just produces a flat list,
使用那个名字来命名一个不提供这些保证的并行算法可能是一个错误。有趣。是的，好吧，我觉得我们又超时了，而且我觉得还有第三个话题我们应该讨论，因为我们本应重温我们在第一集中说要讨论的所有内容，然后我们只是聊了聊三角形积。哦，是的，是的。我可以很快地总结这一集，只要说如果你还记得第零集中外积是什么，回顾一下，基本上是一个笛卡尔积，你取两个列表并生成这两个列表元素的所有可能组合，除了笛卡尔积只是产生一个扁平列表，
whereas outer product produces a matrix with the dimensions of the lengths of your two lists. A triangle product basically avoids the duplicates. So if you imagine yourself with a matrix, just looking at the upper triangular matrix of that sort of matrix that you started with is what triangle product does. Because a lot of times when you're using outer product to perform some binary operation on pairs of elements from two lists, you don't actually want to do the operation twice for, you know, the pair at index 2, 10. You don't want to also repeat the operation for the pair of elements at 10, 2, which is basically the same elements just reversed. Obviously, if your binary operation is something
而外积产生一个维度为两个列表长度的矩阵。三角形积基本上避免了重复。所以如果你想象自己有一个矩阵，只看你开始的那个矩阵的上三角矩阵，这就是三角形积所做的。因为很多时候当你使用外积对来自两个列表的元素对执行某种二元操作时，你其实并不想对索引 2, 10 的那对元素执行两次操作。你也不想对 10, 2 的元素对重复该操作，这基本上是相同的元素只是反转了。显然，如果你的二元操作是某种
like minus, that's not associative, you're going to want to perform that in both directions. But for something like multiplies or plus, you don't actually need to do that. And you can save yourself like twice as many computations. So a triangle product is basically just an outer product that only takes the upper triangular of the matrix, which is a common pattern in array-oriented languages. But as I mentioned in episode zero, I have not found an algorithm in any language that does this kind of thing. But probably our listeners are thinking it's super niche, which it is. But when you want it, it's irritating to have to compose it yourself.
像减法这样不满足结合律的操作，你会想在两个方向上都执行它。但对于像乘法或加法这样的操作，你其实不需要这样做。你可以节省两倍的计算量。所以三角形积基本上只是一个只取矩阵上三角的外积，这是面向数组语言中的一种常见模式。但正如我在第零集中提到的，我还没有在任何语言中找到做这种事情的算法。但可能我们的听众会觉得它非常小众，确实如此。但当你需要它时，不得不自己组合它会很烦人。
And I've run into it many times so i think with that we talked about transform reduce more comprehensively we actually talked about where we work and what languages we've worked in and we talked about triangle product anything else we need to mention before we call it i think we should call it. All right. And are we going to be releasing these on Fridays or Tuesdays? I think that's... I'm going to delegate that decision to you. Okay.
我遇到过很多次，所以我想我们已经更全面地讨论了 transform reduce，我们实际上讨论了我们在哪里工作以及我们使用过什么语言，我们还讨论了三角形积。在我们结束之前还有什么需要提到的吗？我想我们应该结束了。好的。我们是周五还是周二发布这些？我想那是……我把那个决定权交给你。好的。
Our first one was released on Friday. We might release this one on Tuesday because apparently Tuesdays might be better than Fridays for some reason. Yeah, there's some data to that effect. Alrighty. With that, thanks for listening. We'll see you in the next one. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的第一集是在周五发布的。我们可能在周二发布这一集，因为显然周二可能因为某种原因比周五更好。是的，有一些数据支持这一点。好的。就这样，感谢收听。我们下一集见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。